hey youtubers is Charlie so we have
details on when the flash arrow
everything is coming back most of its
business as usual but there are a few
surprises important stuff first I'll do
the premiere dates then I'll explain
what's going on in and around the
premiere when we're going to see new
flash stuff like when we're going to see
an actual trailer all the comic-con
stuff that's happening so season 3 of
the flash starts October 4th arrow
starts the next day then that Friday on
the 7th this is going to sound kind of
weird Supergirl is premiering but here's
the thing it's a Monday night show
they're just airing the first episode on
Friday I'm not exactly sure why they're
doing this they'll probably explain it
later this year but we'll get that first
episode a couple days earlier than we
normally would then that next Monday it
seems like they're going to air a new
episode of Supergirl
or they might re-air the first episode
just so that they show it twice within a
couple days sometimes networks do that
when really big things happen they'll
show an episode a couple times during
the same week so Supergirl is a Monday
night show it's during the same time it
was when it was on CBS but it's on CW
now so it's Monday nights at 8 p.m. but
then that next week when everything is
in its second episode legends of
tomorrow starts so legends of tomorrow
doesn't start till the week after flash
arrow and Supergirl start the reason for
that is because there's only 16 episodes
but that's one of the other surprises is
that they're premiering it during the
fall they're not going to hold it till
the second half of the season like they
did this year I think it's going to be a
lot better that way so what you're going
to have this fall is Monday Supergirl
Tuesday flash Wednesday arrow Thursday
legends of tomorrow what about the big
four and I crossover that's probably
going to be episode eight just because
they do the big arrow flash crossover
episode eight every year so just plan on
that coming during November sweeps if
you don't know what that is is a United
States advertising term don't worry
about it just expect episode eight to be
the big four night crossover so episode
eight of each of the shows will line up
but they'll probably explain more about
that when we get to comic-con
later this year they'll be hyping it up
big time and that's also when we're
probably going to see footage from all
these new shows they'll show it off at
Comic Con then they'll post it online
they're usually really good about
posting stuff so we'll do videos for all
that stuff when it comes I'll talk a
little more about Comic Con stuff when I
do a Comic Con preview video but it's
going to be like they did last year with
like the big panel with all the
different shows they'll trot them out
they'll say a few funny things about
filming Phil T's
some things for next season err a quick
trailer and that's it it's all very
highly choreographed they don't do a lot
of QA because QA zat big Comic Con
panels are genuinely nightmares if
you've ever been to Hall H and you've
seen button lady you understand like
these people asked the weirdest
questions it's really just a soapbox for
the really weird people to come out of
the woodwork so if you don't make it
into comic-con don't worry there's
really only a few times when there's
exclusive footage to Hall age that they
don't release online that's very seldom
does that happen nowadays usually you
can find everything the biggest things
I'm expecting is them to tease the big
villain on the flash like they teased
with zoom I don't think they said right
away that it was zoom they just showed
the blue lightning racing across the
screen everyone's like what the hell is
that they might even show off Tyler
hoechlin Superman suit we don't know
what it's going to look like I assume
it's going to be closer to what the suit
looks like in the movies just a little
more practical
they'll probably tease some Justice
Society stuff for legends of tomorrow
some of the new characters they've
swapped out a whole bunch of the cast so
the people that you see week to week
will be very different but really the
main attraction is seeing the footage
like show us some actual footage shows
to trailer so there'll be plenty of that
but then in August there'll be a second
season of the animated vixen series if
you didn't see the first season they
aired it on the CW you see it is just a
digital streaming service that the CW
owns it's basically like their version
of Hulu so they'll premiere that then
air in episode each week leading up to
the premiere of arrow and flash I don't
really know what the story is going to
be for vixen season 2 only that it's
going to work just like vixen season 1
as you know vixen is coming to legends
of tomorrow but they had to recast the
role so because they didn't want to get
too crazy with the logic about the
recasting they're gonna pull someone
from earlier in vixens timeline like her
mother or her grandmother that'll be the
vixen on legends of tomorrow I mean it
could be her daughter it will be a
different version of the character from
somewhere else in the timeline so I
don't know if the suit is gonna look
different but the powers will work the
same what about the flash though they'll
probably tease some stuff that's going
to be happening they'll probably explain
how Barry is going to change the
timeline without spoiling things too
much for the new season I know the
biggest question especially comic book
readers are asking is is will this
affect any of the other shows I would
say very little so they're doing a
flashpoint storyline but in name only
Barry goes back in time
saves his mother alters the timeline but
the consequences of that will be very
different from the consequences of the
comic book storyline so like when we get
to arrow Oliver Queen is going to be
mayor
they might say some things about Barry's
life being a little bit different they
might address it in a roundabout way the
arrow is mostly going to be concerned
with its own storyline with Oliver Queen
versus the new district attorney who's
going to be the antagonist for the
season so I'll explain that when I post
my arrow video but the same goes for all
the other shows the only other really
important stuff is that Supergirl is
going to have 20 episodes I know people
were like is it going to still have 20
episodes even though they're going to
have less money whatever it is that they
did behind the scenes to work it out
it's 20 episodes so arrow and flash are
both 23 episodes legends of tomorrow is
still 16 episodes Supergirl is 20
episodes Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday so be sure to set your DVRs all
the actors have been on vacation thus
far so I think they go back in the next
week to start shooting so we actually
might hear more about castings that they
make they've announced way more
characters for the other shows than they
have for the flash but I think that's
just because they want to hold it close
to the best they have some really cool
stuff coming so I will totally do videos
for that when it comes I've already done
at least one season three cast video for
the flash they've cast someone that
sounds like it could be dr. alchemy it
could be max mercury it's going to be
someone who seems kind of friendly but
very mistrustful of Barry so not
necessarily an antagonist he's not going
to be the big villain so there's a whole
bunch of other people that they'll cast
that will probably hear about in the
next couple weeks what I'll do next will
probably be civil war then I'll do arrow
season 5 and then we have Sunday Game of
Thrones so
bunch of Game of Thrones coming on
Sunday so there's any other bonus videos
that you guys want for flash arrow
Supergirl legends Justice Society stuff
just let me know in the comments while
you guys wait for me to post that next
video you can click here tour all about
that new cast member on the flash season
3 and you can click here to learn all
about the new spider-man homecoming
villain a couple of the other cast
members for that movie thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight